le président sortant équatorien lenin
moreno connaît son successeur les
résultats provisoires du second tour ne
laisse plus beaucoup de place au doute
et c'est un homme de droite qui dirigera
le pays pour les quatre prochaines
années
le conservateur guillermo olaso ex
banquier s'est proclamé président de
l'équateur avant même la fin du
dépouillement le 24 mai prochain nous
assumerons avec responsabilité le défi
de changer le destin de notre patrie et
à atteindre pour tous l'équateur
d'opportunités de prospérité auquel nous
aspirons
face à lui le jeune économiste andré
sahara où ce protégé de l'ancien
président socialiste rafael correa a
indiqué reconnaissant sa défaite dans
les urnes
c'est un revers électoral mais ça ne
signifie pas une défaite politique ou
morale monsieur l'assaut je vous appelle
à respecter l'état de droit
je vous demande de respecter l'état de
droit là elle ne sert à rien discutons
démocratiquement sans que ce soit une
menace pour les citoyens
guillermo olaso pourra notamment pour
des fils de redresser l'économie de
l'équateur très touchée par les
conséquences de la pandémie de coved 19
l'état sud-américain qui déplore plus de
17000 décès liés au virus